if you speak to a feminist she's going
to say oh it's about the equality of men
and women i don't think it is anymore
it's about the woman's right to choose
her own destiny and i think that's
important i think that's great you know
i clearly have my own career or whatever
but that's because i believe in
individual empowerment i think everybody
should be empowered to save themselves
as a woman you shouldn't rely on a
husband you shouldn't rely on the
government you shouldn't rely on daddy
whatever you need to be empowered
because you don't know what's coming
tomorrow and so that's essential but
we're now at a point whereby feminism i
think has gone too far if a man holds
the door for you what are you doing i
can hold my own door these things are so
integrated into society i'm from london
and when i was 21 i used to work as a
journalist and i carried all this heavy
equipment by myself on the london
underground up and down the stairs not
one man ever offered to help me i could
see it they looked at me but then oh
should i should i not should i i'm like
yes help me i'm a little woman it's okay
i'm not offended but they never did
because they were afraid that they would
offend me so i think feminism has gone
too far it's now rejecting the feminine
the leia plan show